[تصفيق]
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في النقل الحي
والمباشر لتتويج تشارلز الثالث ملكا
للمملكه المتحده وصلنا في هذه المراسم كما
نشاهد في هذه اللحظات امامنا الى هذه
الصوره لقوات المسلحه البريطانيه والتي
كانت تؤدي التحيه للملك تشالت الثالث
مسيره الملك تشيلسي وايضا الملكه كاملا
كانت قد انطلقت من قصر باكينغهام باتجاهي
كنيسه مونستر وبعد ان اديت كل
الطق الطقوس والاعراف في تتويج الملك بكل
مراحلها
سواء في مرحلتها الاولى
بالاقرار الجلوس على كرسي القديس ادوارد
او كرسي التتويج كما يطلق عليه ومرحله
القسم والمسح بالزيت المقدس ايضا كذلك
استلام ايضا الملك للرموز الملكيه الكره
الذهبيه الصولجان وغيرها ايضا وبعد ذلك
ايضا مرحله التنصيب
وايضا مرحله ايضا الجلوس على
العرش ووضع التاج تاج الملكه ماري على راس
الملكه
كامل وبعد ذلك وهو تاج طبعا الملكه ماري
غادر الكنيسه
باتجاه قصر باكينغهام مره اخرى هذه الشرفه
التي من المنتظر ان يطل منها الملك الجديد
البريطاني الملك تشارلز الثالث وهو الذي
طبعا خلف والدته
الراحله الملكه اليزابيث في سبتمبر في
التاسع من سبتمبر الماضي هذه الشرفه
امامنا سيطل منها الملك تشارلز الثالث
وايضا زوجته الملكه كاملا وعدد من افراد
العائله المالكه لتحيه البريطانيين لالقاء
التحيه والسلام ايضا على كل هذه الحشود
التي تجمعت وتجمهره ايضا لمتابعه تفاصيل
وادق تفاصيل هذا التتويج الملكي الذي يحدث
للمره الاولى منذ 70 عاما منذ تتويج
الملكه الراحله اليزابيث عام
1953 انطلقت مسيره التتويج الملكيه كما
ذكرنا من كنيسه
ويسترن باتجاه قصر وصلت هذه المسيره للملك
وللملكه ايضا
وكانت العربه الذهبيه هي من تقلهما الى
قصر
بانتظار ان يطل من الشرفه الملكيه للقاء
التحيه على كل هذه الجماهير والحشود
الموجوده في العاصمه البريطانيه
من لندن تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كارينا
كامل كارينا مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
المباشره كارينا ما الذي تبقى من
جدول الملك تشارلز الثالث هذا اليوم يمكن
الحديث عنه باسهاب
ربما المراحل النهائيه من المراسم التي من
المتوقع ان تستمر لمده 43 دقيقه اضافيه
منذ الصباح الباكر ولكن
الاستعراضات الجويه من قبل الطائرات
العسكريه والحربيه هي التي ربما يتم
التركيز عليها وملفت انه هذه الاستعراضات
التي تشمل تشمل الستين طائره حربيه هي
ليست فقط متركزه هنا في لندن ولكن فعليا
بدات منذ حوالي 45 دقيقه في مناطق مختلفه
حول المملكه المتحده مثلا في شاطئ نورف
شاطئ شمالي شرقي هنا في بريطانيا منطقه
ايضا هذه الاستعراضات بدات قبل حوالي 45
دقيقه
وتستمر في مناطق اخرى ايضا في منطقه
حتى الساعه الثالثه ظهرا بالتوقيت المحلي
وبالتالي الاستعراض طبعا سيكون ايضا متركز
في الساعه الثانيه ونصف تقريبا او قبل ذلك
بقليل امام قصر باكيهام الفرقه المعروفه
من الرد ارنولد وهي فئه يعني ذات خصوصيه
ودات اهميه كبيره في القوات الحربيه
البريطانيه هذه الط ائرات الحمراء التي
ستخلى امام
في استعراض جوي خاص هنا في لندن تحديدا
وسيتابعه الملك من شرطه قصر باكيهام تمت
الان الاستعراضات التي تشاهدها او التحيات
بالاحرى الملكيه من قبل عناصر القوات
المسلحه سواء كان عناصر قوات البحريه او
القوات الجويه كذلك شاركت وتدعنا كذلك
مشاركه العناصر من الجيوش من الدول الاخرى
او قوات عسكريه من دول اخرى اكثر من 30
دوله ساهمت في التحيه الملكيه التي قدمت
في حديقه قصر من هذه الحديقه التي عاده ما
تقام فيها الحفلات الجارد التي اعتدت
الملكه اليزابيث ان تقيمها وبالمناسبه
اقيم حفل يوم الاربعاء من هذا الاسبوع
ايضا من اول حفل يقيمه بالمناسبه اول جولد
او حفلتي الحديقه يقيموا الملك تشارلز بعد
تواليه او بعد جلوسه على العرش كان يوم
الاربعاء من هذا
وكل التركيز الان هو على شركه باكيهام في
هذا السياق يجب ايضا ان نذكر ان هناك
تقارير تتحدث عن انه الامير هاري غادر هذه
المنطقه المركزيه فعليا نحن يعني تابعنا
خروجه من دير ولكن لا نفهمه هو انه لم
يتوجه الى القصر مع باقي اعضاء العائله
بطبعه تبعنا مشاركه الامير هيليوم وزوجته
واولاده في العربه التي كانت خلف الملك
سعرج وكامله وطبعا
اميره ان كذلك
ولكن في نفس الوقت ايضا بطبع زوج ادنبرا
وزوجته توفي ولكن علامه استفهام كبيره من
بين هؤلاء سيكون واقف الى جانب الملك على
شرفه قتل هام من المرجح الا يكون الامير
هاني متواجد البعض يقول انه من الممكن ان
يتوجه حتى مباشره الى المطار ليعود الى
[موسيقى]
اليومان اللذان يعقبان
يوم تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
للمملكه المتحده
يوم غدا الاحد التركيز يتحول الى ويندبر
وبالطبع هي المدينه التي كانت تقيم فيها
الملكه اللجنه خاصه في ايامها الاخيره هي
الامير كان يسكنون في قلعه وين انتقاليه
من قصر الى هناك
خلال جائحه كورونا ولكن بقي هناك حتى بعد
يعني انتهاء فتره الاغلاق في هذا القدس او
في هذه القلعه ملفت ايضا انه قبل عام
تقريبا انتقل الامير بيليه واولادهم ايضا
ليكون الويندر او قتل وينذر المقر الرئيسي
بالنسبه لهما بدلا من قصر كنز
يعني حين ذاك كان يعني كان القرار سكن قبل
وفاه الملكه اليزابيث وكان ربما يهدف لي
يعني امضاء اكثر وقت ممكن من قرب من
الملائكه والان قرروا البقاء هناك فعليا
الويندر يعني واختيار ويندوز كربما المقر
لاقامه هذا الحفل الكبير الذي ننتظره حفل
غنائي حفل استعراضي يوم غد في غرض الاهميه
ايضا لانه يشدد على اهميه ويندوز ايضا نحن
نتحدث عن عائله ويلز العائله الملكيه هي
عائله ليس فقط ليس فقط ولكن مقر اخر ايضا
في غايه الاهميه بالنسبه لي اعضاء هذه
العائله الحفل من المتوقع ان يشمل
استعراضات غنائيه وغيرها من اعضاء ليس
عفوا من فنانين ليس فقط بريطانيين ولكن
مثلا شاهدنا في داخل دير بعض المشاهير
مثلا
المغني الامريكي المشهور حتى باري كانت
متواجده من المتوقع ان تشارك يوم غداء
ايضا الى جانب عدد كبير من الفنانين
البريطانيين والعالمين كما كان الوضع
ونذكر هنا المشاهدين في البلاتيني
للملكه اليزابيث في يونيو من سند وفاتها
من عام 22 اقيم حفل ض في الساحه القناه
مقصبه في الهام جرس فيه العشرات من
الفنانين من حول العالم وكانت هناك فرصه
لعمه الشعب تبعت هذا الحدث يعني من ارض
الواقع ولكن ايضا او من الموقع اضافه طبعا
الى على الشاشه فهذا بالنسبه ليوم غدا احد
واخيرا يوم الاثنين هو ربما اليوم الخيري
قد نقول يوم التركيز على الجهات الخيريه
على الاعمال التطوع في اشاره واضحه من
الملك على حده على اشراق كل اطراف المجتمع
وايضا هي اشاره مهمه جدا من الملك انه يعي
جيدا وحديث على يعني ان تكون هناك حساسيه
للوضع الاقتصادي وان هناك اعداد كبيره من
المتظاهرين بسبب ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وهي
فرصه من ناحيه اعطاء الجميع يعني يوم
اجازه اضافي
لامضاء الوقت مع افراد العائله ويعني
الذهاب الى تندوات المختلفه ولكن ايضا من
جانب اخر لتكون الف المواطن العادي ايضا
ان يساهم في الاعمال الخيريه والاعمال
التطوعيه ليتذكر الجميع هؤلاء الفقراء
والمتدربين طبعا اقل من خمس دقائق حسب
الجدول طبعا الذي
الجدول المعروف
لهذه
لهذه المراسم مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز
ملكه للمملكه المتحده بعد ان ادى القسم
ملكا لبريطانيا من المتوقع ان يظهر الملك
تشارلز والملكه كامله
وافراد من العائله الملكيه على شرطه القصر
لتحيه المحتشدين بالقرب من القصر التحيه
عليهم ايضا وكذلك لمتابعه
الطلعات الجويه والتشكيلات الجويه التي
ستشمل مئات الطائرات اذا طائرات السهام
الحمراء كما هو متعارف عليه كذلك في
البروتوكولات الخاصه بتتويج
الملوك وملكات بريطانيا السؤال ايضا كذلك
عن الاجواء عن الطقس اليوم في لندن يبدو
بانه طقس بارد طقس ممطر ايضا كذلك يعني
يمكن ان يؤثر على اي من ما بقي من مراسم
هذا التتويج كريم
بلا شك وجيده انك سالت هذا السؤال لانه
هناك تقارير الان تتحدث عن ربما تقليص مده
الاستعراض الجوي وايضا تقنيه عدد الطائرات
المشاركه ما نفهمه الان هو ان على الاقل
ما سيتم يعني الاستعراض الذي سيتم في لند
تحديدا سيشمل المروحيات وايضا
الطائرات الاسهم الحمراء فقط لن يشمل يعني
درازات اخرى من الطائرات نظرا من سوء
الاحوال الجويه ايضا مده هذا الاستعراض
الان ستكون دقيقتين ثانيه ومن المتوقع ان
تبدا بعد حوالي 15 دقيقه من الان وطبعا
كما ذكرنا العائله الملكه ستتابع هذا
الحدث من شرطه عفوا
ولكن بالنسبه للجو استطيع ان اقول لك ونحن
متواجدين في شوارع لندن منذ الصباح الباكر
يعني كان في خوف ربما انه وكان من المعروف
مسبقا
يعني تقريبا المطر لم يتوقف منذ اعتقد
الساعه الثامنه صباحا نحن يعني فعلنا
بالامطار ونحن نقوم بتغطيه الاوضاع على
ارض الوا
قع الامطار ملفت جدا انها يعني لم تؤثر
على مستوى الاقبال من المواطنين على
القدوم الى هذا المكان ولكن الكل مستعد
بالملابس الخاصه لهذا الجو الصعب والكل
جالس وفي حاله انتظار يعني طوال
المراسم داخل البير والتعاثا طويله وطبعا
الكل جاء مبكرا انه مواقع المشاهده افتتحت
منذ الساعه السادسه صباحا وحتى البعض كان
متواجد من ايام وامر ليالي في المطر
منتظرين يعني النقد المحوريه وهذا الموقف
فرغم حاله الجو السيئه لم تقلل من الاقبال
لم تقلل من الحماس والان انا متواجده
بجوار مقر الموكب في ميدلي مثلا استطيع
اقول لك ان هناك العشرات من الالاف من
الاشخاص يتوافدون على هذا المجال لانهم
خرجوا الان من دمار او خرجوا من خرب انتهى
اكيد هناك
الاعداد كبيره متبقيه لترى الملك على
الشرفه وترى من سيكون الى جانسي يعني
بجانبه ولكن اعداد كبيره ايضا بدات ربما
تتوجه
الانفاق وتتوجه في المناطق المختلفه في
لندن اي شخص ذهب الى لندن يعرف انه يجب ان
يكون يعني اخيرا في اعتبار حاله تجول
متقلبه التي تكون سيئه في العديد من
الاحيان ولكن الكل يعرف ايضا انه الشعب
البريطاني ومن يعيش في لندن يعني لا يتخذ
هذه الامور بجديه ويواصل عمله
ويعني لا تؤثر ربما بشكل مباشر على الامور
التي يحاول القيام بها ويعني يمر اليوم
كما كان مقررا رغم او بغض النظر عن سوء
الاحوال الجويه طيب نحن لا زلنا معك كما
ذكرتي وتاكيدا ايضا لما قلت كارينا هناك
الالاف يحتشدون الان امامنا كما نشاهد على
شاشه العربيه في الساحات العامه طبعا في
لندن او حتى بالقرب من القصر
قصر الملكي وهو قصر باكينغه بانتظار الان
خروج الملك تشارلز الثالث والملكه ايضا
وافراد من العائله لالقاء التحيه على
الموجودين اسفل القصر من العامه الذين
يحضرون هذا التتويج وهذا اليوم التاريخي
طبعا تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
ملكا للمملكه المتحده المراسم التي
تابعتها معكم العربيه منذ
ظهر اليوم في تمام التاسع بتوقيت جرينيتش
الثاني عشر بتوقيت السعوديه ظهرا
من المنتظر ان يطل الملك تشارلز الثالث
وزوجته الملكه كاملا من هذه الشرفه وبعد
ذلك سنكون ايضا امام عرض
للطائرات الحمراء طائرات السهام الحمراء
ستحلق فوق القصر على مدى خمس دقائق وهي
تشمل افراد من الجيش من البحريه الملكيه
والقوات الجويه ايضا كذلك
ملكيه
قصر قصر باكينغهام كان قد اكد بان الملك
تشارلز والملكه كاملا سوف يواصلان اتباع
هذا التقليد طبعا الخروج من شرفه القصر
قصر باكينغهام والقاء التحيه على هذه
الجماهير التي احتشدت من داخل لندن ومن
خارج لندن ومن خارج ايضا حتى
بريطانيا
ونتابع ايضا انتشار امني مكثف امامنا في
هذه
الصوره التي نتابعها مباشره
[موسيقى]
لازلنا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره لاحتشادي الالاف من المتجاهلين
في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن بعد مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارلز يبدو الان الانتشار
اصبح كثيفا وربما سمحت
وربما ايضا سمحت الشرطه كذلك
امامنا
للجماهير بالاقتراب اكثر من قصر باكينغهام
في هذه الصور
المباشره
وبانتظار كما ذكرنا ان يلقي الملك تشارلز
الثالث وزوجته الملكه كامل التحيه على كل
هذه الجماهير التي احتجت في يوم تنصيب
وفي اليوم طبعا الذي يتوج في الملك تشارلز
الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده كما نشاهد
امامنا الان على شاشه العربيه
انضم الي من جده باسل الغلايين وهو احد
اصدقاء الملك تشارلز سيد باسل مرحبا بك
معي الكثير ممن يتابع هذه
المراسم وهذا التتويج للملك تشارلز يسال
عن الشخصيه شخصيه الملك التي لا تظهر على
شاشات التلفزه الشخصيته مع اصدقائه مع
المقربين ايضا منه كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
وابرز ملامحها كذلك
حياك الله بدايه ودي ابارك
الشعب البريطاني
صديق
بتتويج الملك تشارلز ملكا لايطاليا
انا تعرفت على الملك تشارلز من حوالي 26
سنه يعيد الى مباراه بولو خيريه هو كان
كابتن الفريق فيها
وبكر لك كيف البؤلؤ في المملكه مباراه في
المملكه ايش رايك لو انا ابدا في مباريات
خيريه في بريطانيا ويصير فيها تبرع
للجمعيات الخيريه في المملكه المتحده وفي
المملكه السعوديه وهذا كانت بدايه العلاقه
معاه وصارت كل سنه يصير هو يشارك في
مباريات الكولا هذه انا تعرفت عليه يعني
قابلته حوالي 15 مره تقريبا وكان يجي ايام
الملك الراحله مشارك في القولون نفسها في
المباراه
وكان يجيب معاه الامير ويليام الارهابي
يلعبوا معي كذلك
[موسيقى]
ممتاز الناس تريد ان تعرف عن شخصيه الملك
عن
تعامله عن التعامل مع الاصدقاء مع من يعمل
ايضا كذلك معهم يعني حتى في ابسط الامور
وادق هذه التفاصيل في مباريات خيريه في
اهتماماته ايضا سواء بالرياضه بالبيئه
وغيرها
قصه جدا رائعه
انا من حوالي
18 سنه جاني ابني بدر والظاهر
قصره انه الاخ باسل
بتهنئه مباشره
شهرين ارسل له رساله موقع منه انه انا اسف
اني
بقدوم ابنك بدر وهذه تهنئه خاصه
فكانت يعني لست
جميله جدا انه يعني ما نفسي
المباركه هذه على
المكان معنا في في المباراه الاخيره في
كذلك
صارت مع
حاتم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان لما
جانك ضيف شرف في احدى المباريات وكانت
تمطر بشكل غزير
فريق ملكه تشارلز هو المباراه فقال له
الملك سلمان ترى وجهك وجه سعد علي بسببك
انا مباراه مع انه الوزن مساعد
يعني جميله حلوه
يعني اللي يتعاملوا معاه
وخاصه اهتمامه بالعمل الخيري يعني مثل ما
تعرف عنده مؤسسه خيريه تحتها حوالي 700
شركه او 70 مؤسسه خيريه
بمجال التعليم مجال الصحه
مجال
يسموها صحيح صحيح حتى وحتى يوم الاثنين
القادم هو يوم خصصه الملك تشارلز الثالث
للتطوع في كامل بريطانيا ايضا وهو يوم
اجازه في بريطانيا على كل انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه معي على هذه
المشاركه اليوم في تتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده لا زلنا
واياكم مشاهدينا نتابع هذه صور الشكر
للسيد باسل الغلياني واحد استيقا طبعا
الملك
تشارلز لازلنا نتابع واياكم هذه الصور
لالاف
المحتشدين في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن بعد
مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز وهي التي تصل
الى نهايتها في انتظار طبعا
ان يطل من شرفه قصر باكينج هاملي تحيه
الجماهير التي تحتشد الان امامنا امام قصر
طبعا
تنضم اليه الملكه كاملا زوجه الملك تشارلز
الثالث
وطبعا هذه الحشود التي ستتجمع امام القصر
طبعا تشاهد رفقه الملك
عرضا جويا
لتشكيلات جويه تحلق فوق القصر على مدى خمس
دقائق ستشمل افراد من الجيش من البحريه
الملكيه والقوات الجويه الملكيه ايضا كذلك
كما نشاهد امامنا هذه الشرطه التي سيطل
منها بعد قليل اعود مره اخرى الى
شبكه مراسلي العربيه من لندن من هناك
مديره مكتب العربيه في لندن ومكتبي ريما
مرحبا بانضمامك الي مجددا كان من المقرر
يعني ان تكون الاطلاله الملك من الشرفه
رفقه الملكه كاملا عند الواحده والربع
بتوقيت جرينتش لكن يبدو ان الامور حتى هذه
اللحظه او لاطل الملك اطل الملك الان من
شرطه القصر الى جانب زوجته كملا ايضا
ويتقدمان الان لربما القاء التحيه كذلك
على الاف المحتشرين من الجماهير رفقه
اعضاء الاسره الملكيه ايضا الملك يلقي
التحيه الان على كل هذه الجماهير التي
تحتشد وهو كما ذكرنا يرتدي التاج التاج
الامبراطوري
وكذلك ايضا الملكه كاملا ترتدي تاج
الملكه
[تصفيق]
صحيح تم يعني فك الطوق الامني فورا انتهاء
القوات المسلحه من دول من بريطانيا ودول
الكومنويلز 30 على اقل
فتحت الطرقات وسمح للناس بالتوجه الى محيط
قصر باكنجهام افتاحا بالمجال الملك لخروجه
بالجدول الاساسي كان من المتوقع ان يطل
الملك على الشرفه قبل عشر دقائق هذا هو
الان
نستمع
للحظات التي يعني يحيي فيها الجماهير
الملك والملكه
مهم جدا ان نرى من سيكون على الشرطه في
هذه الاثناء لماذا لانه هذه هي
الرسائل السياسيه المباشره التي يعطيها
الملك انا لا اعلم ريما ان كنت
تشاهدين امامك الشاشه الان او ربما الهاتف
المتنقل لمشاهده البث المباشر لكن يتواجد
الامير ويليام وكذلك ايضا الاميره ان زوجه
او عفوا اخت الملك تشارلز لا اعلم ان كنت
تشاهدينه
[تصفيق]
نعم
الامير وليم ولي العهد والملكه
الجميع متواجد على الشرطه لا وجود الامير
هاري وهو شقيق ولي العهد وهناك ايضا افراد
من عائله كاملا على ما اظن موجودين على
الشرطه
موجودين
اتفاق لكن بقي وطبعا زوجه ولي العهد
موجوده على
كل ما يعني
من سيكون على هذه الشرطه من سيغيب من
سيحضر
هذه مشاهد ولي العهد وزوجته الاميره كيت
والابناء ابناء الامير ويليام طبعا الثالث
هو الامير جورج وهو ثالث في ترتيب العرش
الملك تشارز متوجا والملكه كاملا احفاد
كاملا من زوجها الاول باركربون على فكره
حتى زوج كان داخل الزوج الاول للملكه
كاملا كان داخل الكنيسه وحتى كما قرا مكان
بعرس تشارلز وكابيلا بقيت العائله متماسكه
نوعا ما رغم
الطلاق والحشود
المجال بالالاف يعني كان هناك تهاب غريب
وعمليات ركض لمن ياتي اولا لابواب قصر
باكينغهام لالقاء التحيه على الملك تشارل
نعم وهو يطل الان من الشرفه كما ذكرت
الاحفاد ايضا يلقون التحيه كذلك في هذه
الصوره للملك تشارلز الثالث ربما الان ان
هذا العرض الجوي قد بدا امامنا الان ريما
ونحن نشاهد
الطائرات اذا حربيه وهي تحلق فوق قصر
باكينغهام ما هي التفاصيل هذه الطلعات
الجويه
هذه تحيه سلاح الجو ولكن بالماضي كان
يستمر ست دقائق اليوم سيستمر لدقيقتين
وثلاثين ثانيه اولا بسبب سوء الاحوال
الجويه في بريطانيا لم يحالف الحظ ابدا
الاحتفالات اليوم الطقس سيء في لندن وتم
اختصار العرض الجوي الى دقيقتين و30 ثانيه
وهي تحيه س
لاح الجو
فعلا بدا الان امامنا
وهي وهم من ابنائها واحفادها من زواج
الاول احفاد الملك تشارلز ولي العهد
وابناء اصدقاء ايضا موجودين
على شاشه تتجه ربما ريما لهذا العرض الجوي
في سماء العاصمه لندن
وغياب الامير هاري كذلك
سلاح الجو
للملك تشارلز
سبب رجاءه
بمروحيات وهي تحيه القوات الجويه
اذا تم اختصارها الى دقيقتين ونصف وكذلك
ايضا تم اقتصارها فقط على هذه المروحيات
التي نشاهد الان تحليقها فوق قصر باكينج
هام
للقاء التحيه ايضا كذلك تقليد بريطاني
اصيل وعريق ايضا كذلك العائله
المالكه والاسره الملكيه ايضا البريطانيه
وهي تشاهد ايضا هذه الطائرات رفقه من
احتشد من الجماهير تحت قصر باكينج هام
لمشاهده الملك تشارلز الثالث والملكه
كامله وهما متوجاني
بالملكيه المطلقه في المملكه المتحده
عدسات الكاميرا وهي عدسات من شركات خاصه
تديرها الشركات مختصه تابعه لقصر
باركينغهام هو حتى عمليه الاخراج يديرها
قصر باكن بطريقه غير مباشره تسلط الاضواء
على الملك والملكه
ولي العهد وزوجته
الذين يتولون على العرش الامير جو
رج في ابناء الامير ويليام وبناته
في شاشه وهناك نوع من يعني تفادي تسليط
الضوء على باقي افراد العائله الامير هاري
لحظه صعودو لسياره وخروجه من كنيسه مانستر
الاعلام والثقافه صفراء
اعتقد انه غادر البلد لكن ليس واضحا اذا
ما حصل لقاء مباشر بينه وبين والده وينتقل
انه ايضا المره الاولى التي يحضر فيها الى
بريطانيا وينضم للعائله بعدها الان القول
بان العروض الجويه الان
لهذه الطائرات ايضا التي نشاهدها الطائرات
السلاح الجو ربما الملكي البريطاني تخطف
الكثير من الانظار بهذه التشكيلات الفنيه
المختلفه بالوان
الازرق والابيض والاحمر ايضا كذلك وهي
التي ترمز الى العلم
البريطاني ايضا كذلك كريمه
وهي تحيه للملك والملكه
[موسيقى]
ونرى يعني مشاهد جميله جدا هذه لحظات
الاخيره من مراسم التتويج هذه التحيه
نتوقع ان تبقى الحشود في الشوارع المحيطه
والمؤديه الى قصر
قبل قليل هذه ما يطلق عليها طائرات السهام
الحمراء وهي طبعا هذا
يعني حتى بارجاء العاصمه ممكن سماع
ومشاهده الطائرات
وسماء لندن
الرماديه لا
[تصفيق]
تساعد عبد المنظر
[موسيقى]
تحيه الملكيه لا زالت ريما مستمره الان
للملك تشارلز وايضا للملكه كاملا وربما في
هذه اللحظات
[تصفيق]
يعيدون التحيه لكل الجماهير المحتشده
والاف طبعا من وصلوا الى لندن من داخل
بريطانيا او ايضا من المملكه المتحده او
من خارجها ايضا كذلك لحضور هذا التتويج
التاريخي والكبير والمهيب ايضا الذي
تبعناه منذ ظهر اليوم الملكه والملك ايضا
الان يومان بالخروج من
الشرفه والعوده الى قصر باكينج هام بعد ان
وقف الملك الجديد على شرطه قصر باكينغهام
وهو لازال الان يحيي الجماهير وربما قبل
ان يغادرهم ويعود مره اخرى الى قصر باكنج
هام طبعا هذه العاده مشاهدينا جرت منذ
تتويج الملك ادوارد السابع في عام
1902 ان يقف الملك الجديد في شرطه قصر
باكينغهام ريما هل هذا هو
اخر مراحل تتويج الملك تشارلز ان يخرج
ويحيي الناس من شجره باكينغهام لا مراحل
بعد ذلك
انتهى البرنامج وهو على الوقت صراحه لانه
تم تعديل البرنامج ليكون 2.5 توقيت لندن
صرنا اثنين و 35 دقيقه على الوقت في
الثانيه احتفاء البهيب ملكي بامتياز عصري
وفيه قرون قديمه وسنوات مئات سنوات من
التاريخ ومن الطقوس كلها ادخلت الى داخل
كنيسه
وباكينغهام في عرض عسكري وعرض ملكي مهيب
عرض كبير وعبد يوسف بانه عرض كلاسيكي كما
ذكرتي وعريق
بريطانيا لكن ربما من يشاهد هذا العرض
اليوم يسال عن تاريخ بريطانيا في تتويج
ملوكها مقارنه بما حدث اليوم هل هناك من
مراحل مثلا جديده ادخلت في هذا التتويج ام
هناك اعاده فقط للمراحل ولا جديده فيها
ريما من خلال ما تابعتي
جزء عصري لهذه العمليه مثلا تم اشراك عدد
من الاساقفه من خارج بريطانيا من دول
الكومنويلز من الشرق الاوسط تم ايضا تعديل
القسم يعني يدخل جميع الاديان وليس الدين
المسيحي
ايضا اشراك كافه مكونات المجتمع البريطاني
لانه مثلا رئيس الحكومه في اسكتلندا مسلم
رئيس الحكومه في بريطانيا من جذور هنديه
تم تعديل الموسيقى ايضا استخدمت بعض
الموسيقى التي يريدها الملك تشارلز
تعديل بالحضور دعي الى التتويج ملوك
وملكات مع انه هذا لم يكن العرف
والبروتوكول ولكن
بالغالبيه العظمى من برنامج التتويج
بامكاننا القول انه نحن نشاهد تاريخ تاريخ
عمرو مئات سنوات ب 2023
وامام عدسات الكاميرا الان عاد الملك مره
اخرى والملكه ربما لالقاء التحيه مجددا
على يعني الاف المحتشدين في العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن وهذه الصوره للملك تشارلز
الثالث
وزوجته الملكه كاملا وهما يلقيان التحيه
من على شرطه قصر باكينغهام القصر الملكي
عداء الى تحيه
الجماهير ايضا والمحتشدين اسفل القصر من
شرفه باكينج هام كما نشاهد امامنا في هذه
الصوره وهم وهما يرتديان طبعا
التاج تاج الامبراطوري على راس الملك
تشارلز الثالث وتاج الملكه ماري على راس
الملكه كاملا وهي التي تخرج الان مره
ثانيه من الشرفه الى داخل القصر الملك
تشارلز يعيد التحيه على الجماهير التي
احتشدت هو عاده مره اخرى بعد ان خرج القى
عليهم التحيه ايضا كذلك وبهذا تنتهي مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملك المملكه
المتحده باغلاق هذه الشرفه شرفه قصر
باتنهام وعودته الى القصر
لمتابعه ربما احتفالات ايضا ستكون في
القصر مع عائلته الملكيه اذا انتهت مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارلز بعد
يعني احتجاج الالاف في العاصمه لندن هناك
تفصيله فقط تحدثتي عنها بدايه هذا المباشر
ريما وهي الاف المحتشدين امام قصر
باكينغهام هذا الطوق الامني الذي يعني فك
في في لحظه قصيره ربما قبل خروج الملك من
على الشرفه هل كان من المفترض ان يصل
الناس الى هذا القرب من الشرفه
ومن القصر
[موسيقى]
نعم كل الوجه وضعت بيدي
الضباط كبار الضباط
وقوات الامنيه
المجال لهذه اللحظه يريدون مشهد الملك
والملكه على الشرطه
الحشود محاطه بها لذا عندما دخل الملك
والقوات المسلحه تم فك السوق الامني وجاء
الكثيرون للقاء التحيه على الملك رغم
الشخص السيء وافتح مجال كل فريق العمل
للعربيه من ايام في الطرقات وتحت الشتاء
لتغطيه هذا الحدث بشكل تستحقون الشكر على
هذه التغطيه ايضا والعمل الرائع ايضا منذ
ايام يعني ليس منذ اليوم سواء بالسلسله
التقارير التي عرضت خلال الايام الماضي او
حتى ايضا من الخروج مباشره من اماكن
مختلفه من العاصمه البريطانيه لك انت ايضا
نايف بس تاكد انه الامير هاري توجه للمطار
بخبر ورد على وسائل اعلام بريطانيه خرج
الامير هاري من من كنيسه منستر مباشره
بسياره الى المطار ليغادر المملكه المتحده
باتجاه يونيسترو حضر الاحتفال وغادر غدا
لم يكن موجودا على الشرفه حتى مثل ما
تبعنا قبل قليل شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات على كل هذه التفاصيل منذ
ظهر اليوم من لندن مديره مكتب العربيه
هناك مكتبي شكرا جزيلا لك ابقى مع
شبكه مراسلي العربيه في لندن ايضا الى
كارينا كامل من موقع اخر كارينا ربما انت
يعني ترصدين الحاله العامه الاحتفالات
العارمه ايضا كذلك في العاصمه البريطانيه
لندن ما الذي تغير في وجه عاصمه الضباب
هذا اليوم
فعلا ربما هي عاصمه الضباب ولكن ايضا
عاصمه الاحتفال يعني لم يخلو ركنا من
العاصمه
الملكيه الاعلام في كل الشوارع نحن هنا في
وسط لندن يعني منذ الصباح الباكر واستطيع
اقول لك انه الكل يتجول حاملا الاعلام
مرتديا الالوان الزرقاء والبيضاء الاعلام
العلامه البريطاني
يعني
ترحب بهذا اليوم التاريخ
ي يعني هناك وجود امني كثير ولكن يعني
بناء على يعني استكمالا لحديثك مع ريما
قبل قليل والقرب الحشود من
اجهزه الامني الوجود الامني مكثف ولكن
يعني يقام بشكل يسمح لي الكل ان تجول
التحرك من مكان الى اخر بسهوله وهنا
مدروسه الهدف من ذلك هو ان يشعر كل شخص
انه بامكانه الاستمتاع بهذا اليوم بامكانه
الوصول الى اقرب نقطه من الق يشارك فعليا
في هذا اليوم وهذا فعليا يعني ضمن الخطه
التي
خطط لها الملك وخطفت لها العائله الملكيه
لتكون فعلا هناك يعني احتياطات امنيه
تحدثنا عن اكبر عمليه امنيه حاليا في
تاريخ القوات الشرطه
لندن في تاريخها فعليا يعني هذا ما اكدته
السلطات الرسميه ولكن في نفس الوقت الشخص
العادي لا يشعر بهذا التواجد الامني لانه
هناك ايضا رجال الشرطه العديدون الذين
مثلا يرتدون الملابس العاديه فلا يشعر احد
بوجودهم ولكن الان استطيع ان اقول لك انه
مع نهايه الجزء الاخير من الاستعراضات
وظهور العائله على فصل
القران العشرات من الالاف يتوافدون الى
وافق على المجاوره
لمول او جرين بارك ويعتمون الى المتاجر
والمطاعم وكلها مفتوحه منذ الصباح وعندما
نتحدث عن الجرعه النشاط التي ستلقاها
الاقتصاد نتيجه هذا الحدث الان ربما سنرى
على ارض الواقع هذا النشاط الاقتصادي
التسوق الى المطاعم شراء المنتجات
التذكاريه امضاء الوقت في لندن يعني الكل
يعرف انه لندن ايضا كانت خاليه الى حد
كبير خلال فتره زايحه وعانت بسبب غياب
العديدون من الاماكن السياحيه مثلا او
الاماكن المركزيه
ما كنت اود السؤال عنها ايضا حتى كارينا
يعني هذا الاحتشاد الكبير الذي شاهدناه
يعني منذ ااا بدايه هذه ال ال المراسم على
يعني جنبات الطرق وايضا حتى كذلك بالقرب
من قصر باكنج هام والميادين المؤديه اليه
هل كانت هناك حركه
قدوم كبيره وسياحيه ايضا من قبل يعني
اشخاص قدموا الى الى لندن بغرض حضور هذه
المناسبه وهذا التقليد البريطاني العريق
امم يعني الحضور اقتصر على من هم موجودين
داخل لندن وبريطانيا بشكل عام
لا ابدا ابدا يعني استطيع ان اقول لك انه
نحن سمعنا يعني كل لغه مختلفه اليوم
وبالمناسبه وسائل الاعلام ايضا من شتى دول
العالم متواجده فعلا يعني حتى الدول لم
يتخيل احد انها
بهذه الدرجه بهذا الحدث في اشاره ربما الى
يعني مدى الاهتمام العالميه بهذا الحدث
وهو فعليا حدث استثنائي يعني عندما نتحدث
ان بريطانيا هي ربما الدوله الوحيده على
الاقل في اوروبا التي تقوم بهكذا تتويج
وبهذا الرجاليه وبهكذا يعني طقوس تعود الى
قرون مضت فعليا اهتمام العالمي وهناك
اجناس مختلفه من ناحيه اعلاميه ولكن من
ناحيه
المتواجدين اكيد هناك اعتقد عشرات الالاف
من انحاء المملكه المتحده لانه مثلا قد
نقول انه كانت هناك استعدادات على الطرق
المؤديه الى لندن خدمتها القطار ايضا قامت
باستعدادات زياده اعداد المتواجدين على
العاصمه اكيد هناك طبعا اغلاق للجوارع
يعني كان فيه ربما حد لحركه المرور في بعض
المناطق الرئيسيه ولكن هذا ايضا سحل حركه
الحركه بالنسبه للمشاه انا قلقان وحولي
فعلا عشره الالاف من الناس يعني يتجولون
في المناطق المركزيه في لندن كل الاجناس
متواجده كل المناطق الاقليميه متواجده كل
الاعمار ايضا هناك العديد من في اعتبار
السن
الاطفال الصغار السن يعني خليط كبير من كل
الجنسيات كل الخلفيات كل الجهات المجتمعيه
المختلفه وهذا فعليا يعني عندما نتحدث عن
اهميه هذا الحدث اكيد هو حدث تاريخي هو
حدث نهيب هو حدث رمزي ولكنه ايضا يعني
يذكرنا بمكانه العائله الملكيه في المجتمع
البريطاني ايا كانت الخلافات والكل يعرف
بريطانيا عانت وما زالت تعاني من خلافات
سواء كانت سياسيه او ثقافيه ولكن الكل
يمكنه الاجماع على انه هناك فعليا احترام
وحب كبير لهذه العائله التي تمثل الجميع
حتى ان كانت عائله عريقه يعني تعود او
يعود تاريخها وتقاليدها الى قانون النظر
ولكنها رغم ذلك تعبر عن بريطانيا الحديثه
بريطانيا المعاصره هذا المجتمع متعدد
الاديان متعدد الاجناس متعدد اللغات
واعتقد انه ما يحدث اليوم على ارض الواقع
في لندن ابرز دليل على ذلك ربما يعني
سيكون سعيدا في خاصيه
الجمهور اليوم وهذا الاهتمام وهذا
الاحتفال ايضا من كل هذه اللجنه المختلفه
داخل وخارج اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه
الصوره التي نقلتيها لنا منذ بدايه طبعا
مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز رفقه الزملاء
ايضا شبكه مراسلي العربيه من مكتب العربيه
في لندن شكرا جزيلا لك كارينا كامل مراسله
العربيه في العاصمه البريطانيه نبقى في
لندن انضم الينا الصحفي محمد شبارو سيد
محمد مرحبا بك معي شاهدت هذا الحفل منذ
ظهر اليوم
اريد السؤال عن الدلالات عن الرمزيه عن
القيمه بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه
تجاه
البريطانيين بعد هذا الحفل وهذه المراسم
الطويله التي بدات في التاسعه بتوقيت
جرينتش هذا اليوم
يعني
اولا لابد من القول اننا نعيش لحظات
تاريخيه بغض النظر من تكون في بريطانيا
اليوم تاثرت بما شاهدت وتابعت عن كثب يعني
اعتلاء العرش وايضا التتويج الذي شاهدناه
بهذا الحفل
يعني يتخطى كل المعايير ويؤكد على تمسك
بريطانيا باعراضها وتقاليدها الضاربه في
جذور التاريخ يعني بشكل او باخر لكن
لابد من انه يقول انه لدى جميع في
بريطانيا وخصوصا المالكه انه المراسم تمت
من دونها فوات او اخطاء ولكن ايضا كان في
موقف واضح انه الواضح ان الشعب البريطاني
بايع
وموافق على بقاء الاسره الحاكمه على راس
السلطه طبعا هي يعني لا تحكم بشكل تنفيذي
ولكن رمزيتها تعني للكثيرين وان شكك بعض
او ان هناك اصوات نافره هنا وهناك عن ان
الملكيه غير نافعه وانها غير مفيده في هذا
الزمن
نعم هناك تحديات امام الملك تشارلز والذي
لاحظنا في اماكن ما بعض التوتر على وجهه
من يعرفه ومن شاهده على مدى الخمسين سنه
الماضيه انا اعيش هنا منذ اربعين عاما في
بريطانيا ونتابع اخبار الملك الذي هو يعني
يعتبر موجود في الاعلام يتم تداوله موجوده
صوره
لم ترى العبء والثقل ثقل المسؤوليه الان
التي اصبحت على عاتقه هناك امر ما تغير
ويحاول
بشتى الصدر ان يبدو رسميا وان يبدو بما
لمحه بعض الابتسام ولكنه هناك عبء عليه ان
يملا او او يعني يقوم بالواجبات وبخدمه
شعبه وبلاده كما كانت يعني
تود والدته الملكه اليزابيث منه ان يكون
بذلك ما هي اهم الواجبات سيد محمد التي
المنوطه اليوم الملك تشارلز الثالث التي
يجب ان يقوم بادائها بشكل مستمر سواء
باتجاه بريطانيا باتجاه علاقاتها ايضا حتى
ربما الخارجيه ايضا حتى اتجاه دول
الكومنوز
البلاط الملكي البريطانيه الاسره الحاكمه
الاسره الملكيه البريطانيه هي رمزيه نعم
ولكن واجباتها كبيره وايضا ما تؤثر في
مساعده البلاد هي يعني القوه الناعمه
لبريطانيا في العالم ولكن حتى داخليا
مساله ان يكون هناك مغزى من الملكيه تعني
ابناء الجيل الجديد ولماذا ندفع كدافعي
ضرائب للابقاء على هذه الاسره الحاكمه
هناك من يقول ان البلاط الملكي سيصبح
مصغرا تحت عهد
تشارلز الثالث او ان يصبح هناك اولويه
للتصدير وعصر النفقات وجعل المؤسسه تسير
بشكل اقتصادي اكبر يعني ربما هي علامه على
زمننا هذا لكنه م
لفات للغايه ان تحجب المال عن اعضاء
عاملين في المؤسسه مؤسسه الحكم منذ سنوات
طويله حالتهم على التقاعد
او عمل
والتحدي الكبير ان معروف عن تشارل اهتمامه
بقضايا سياسيه وقضايا بيئيه كثيره حول
العالم الى اي درجه يمكنه ان يتوائم مع
مؤسسه اي السلطه التنفيذيه رئاسه الحكومه
هناك ايضا دور للاسره الحاكمه التي طالما
رفدت العمل
ناعمه التي تمارسها عبر علاقات القصر
بعائلات مالكه يعني منذ التاريخ مختلفه من
العالم خصوصا مثلا في الخليج ايضا وفي دول
مختلفه في اسيا وفي امريكا اللاتينيه هو
الى اي درجه ستتوائم وسيوائم عمله الملك
تشارل مع اجنده الحكومه
وضروراتها العملانيه التي تتطلب من القصر
التدخل هنا او التدخل هناك كل هذا يعني
يعتبر تحديات صح التعبير راينا تشارل قبل
حفله تتويج قبل اسابيع كان موجودا في
المانيا وتحدث باللغه الالمانيه في نحن
نمر بمرحله حساسه بين العلاقات بين
بريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا فاذا هي
درجه القصر الملكي بامكانه لعب دور
يهبئ او او
[موسيقى]
يقرب من المواقف بين الجانبين والى اي حد
ايضا كذلك يمكن للقصر الملكي اليوم ان ان
يتعامل مع هذه الازمه ازمه معيشيه اضرابات
ايضا تشل البلاد ازمه اقتصاديه ايضا ليست
على بريطانيا فقط على كل ربما دول القاره
العجوز
والعالم ايضا حتى هذا كيف سينعكس على
الملك تشاد في المرحله المقبله سيد محمد
يعني انا كتبت ان
الذي
طرحت
واعتبرها رمزا للعرش وهو قطعه تورته البيض
هي ربما دلاله على هذا الزمن الذي اذا صح
التعبير اقتصاديا لا يمر بشكل جيد هناك
ازمه معيشه هناك ازمه يعني صعوبات لتوفير
الاساسيات في كل منزل ليس فقط في بريطانيا
ولكن حول العالم فانا اعتقد ان من دون شك
القصر يلعب برمزيته دور ايضا المحافظ على
على نبض الذي يشعر بنبض الشارع ويعكسه
بتصرفاته ولذلك سمعنا كثيرا عن خفض
النفقات بما يتعلق بهذا
التتويج ايضا اغتصار المدعوين على 2000
مدعو بدل 8000 مدعو يعني كل ذلك يدخل في
صميم مواكبه الزمن وايضا اذا صح التعبير
قد يحمل تشارلز الكثير من الافكار والاراء
التي سيسر بها سيقولها لرئيس الوزراء بغض
النظر من يكون على راس دا هنا في بريطانيا
سيلعب هذا الدور المكمل اذا صح التعبير
لعكس نبض الشارع وما تحتاجه الامه من خلال
نافذه الاسره الحاكمه على السلطه
التنفيذيه الموجوده في البلاد اليوم ما هي
حدود تاثير الملك تشارلز الثالث على عمل
الحكومه سيد محمد
لا تاثير له على الاطلاق ولكن
من وجهه نظر استشاريه من وجهه نظر مواقفه
معرفته اتصالاته العالميه ايضا انه كان
متدربا على الحكم لمده 70 عاما فله نظره
ثاقبه في شؤون وشجون البلاد اذا احتاجت
السلطه التنفيذيه اي مشهوره فانه موجود
وجاهز ليعطيها وان كان سيسر بها بشكل طبعا
دائما شكل يعني بعيد عن الاضواء ولا تنسب
اليه اي فكره او اي راي ممكن ان يعطيه
فهذه هي يعني مثل منطقه حرام ليس على
العاهل او الملك البريطاني التدخل باي شكل
او يظهر انه يتدخل بالسلطه هذا انتهى منذ
اكثر من 3400 عام ما هو مستقبل دول
الكومنويل مع الرئيس مع الملك تشارلز
الثالث
هناك تحدي كبير طبعا هناك
استفدت سكانها
وقررت ان تتحول الى الى جمهوريه هناك ايضا
دولتان
ثانيتان جامايكا وبليز
تناقشان في برلمان برلماناتهما مساله
الابقاء على
الملك البريطاني رئيسا للدوله ولو كانت
رئاسه فخريه ولكنها كانت منذ استقلال هذه
الدول ما زالوا يحلفون باسم الملك الملك
البريطاني
يعني هناك ايضا اتجاه في انتيجوا وبربوده
وهي يعني الدول صغيره ولكنها مستقله
ولكنها ما زالت قاطعه للتاج الخوف هو طبعا
من دول اكبر مثل كندا او استراليا ان تقوم
ايضا والتي من وقت لاخر يطرح مساله
الاستفتاء فهذا طبعا سيؤثر على
بريطانيا حول العالم لان هناك حوالي 12
دوله حيث الملك البريطاني هو رئيسها
الفعلي لكن ما زال لدى بريطانيا 50 دوله
هي دولت اكثر من 55 دوله فبالتالي
الامبراطوريه التي لا تغيب عنها الشمس ما
زال لديها امتدادات على
بمناطق متعدده
بهذا الكوكب وبالتالي ارث بريطانيا وقوتها
ربما ايضا رغم انح
ساره بخروجه من الاتحاد الاوروبي الا انه
يمكن القول ان سطوطها حتى الان مستمره
واعتقد ان
سيمضي قدما في تعزيز هذا الوجود وايضا
تقريب وجهات النظر اذا كان بين السلطه
المركزيه التنفيذيه في بريطانيا وايضا دول
العالم لتبقى لتبقي بريطانيا على مكانتها
السياديه
هل الملك يعني تغيرت شعبيته في بريطانيا
بعد ان اصبح ملكا لان المؤشرات ربما او
الاحصاءات كانت يعني
تشير الى انخفاض شعبيته عندما كان وليا
للعهد ايام الملكه اليزابيث
انا اعتقد اننا يجب ان نضع الامور في
سياقها ونعطي هذه الاستطلاعات لنرى موقف
الشعب بعد سته اشهر او فتره من مرور الزمن
هنا في بريطانيا لانه
يعني تعود البريطانيون على الامير تشارلز
امير المشاغبا متدخلا مشاكسا في اماكن
حاضرا مبتسما غير رسمي في اماكن اخرى
اليوم هو يرتدي تاج الملك وهو يعني
المرجعيه الاساسيه في القصر الملكي ومؤسسه
الحكم البريطانيه
المؤشرات والاستطلاعات تقول ان هناك قبول
الثلثين لهم ولكن لنرى اذا كانت هذه
الارقام
ربما في المستقبل القريب شكرا جزيلا لك
الصحفي محمد شوبارو انضم الينا من العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن هذه الساعه انتهت
مشاهدينا بعد
متابعه مستمره منذ ظهر
اليوم لمراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز ستبقى
التغطيه مستمره مع زميل رشا نبيل العرائس
الساعه وانا القاكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات